lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar acerca del impuesto sucesorio
impuesto sucesorio y como el nombre del
impuesto implica es el impuesto sobre la
herencia o el legado de alguien cuando
alguien fallece es el impuesto sobre lo
que heredan sobre lo que dejan atrás ya
sea en su testamento o en su familia en
donde ellos indiquen
algunas veces se conoce como impuesto en
la herencia o impuesto a la herencia y
en algunos lugares se refiere a ello
como impuesto de la muerte la idea
general es que digamos que ahora todos
mis bienes
valen 3 millones de dólares
yo valgo 3 millones de dólares y
entonces fallezca por lo que estos 3
millones de dólares van a mi herencia lo
que heredó pueden ser mis ahorros las
propiedades que tengo mi coche en fin
todo lo que yo poseo todo eso combinado
dan 3 millones de dólares que es lo que
yo voy a heredar y digamos que yo voy a
dejar todo lo que está en mi herencia
para mi hija
así que todo esto se lo voy a heredar a
mi hija en este momento es donde entra
el impuesto sucesorio o el impuesto a la
herencia cuánto dinero recibirá mi hija
resulta que para tres millones de
dólares en los eeuu mi hija está exenta
del impuesto pues en las herencias de
individuos los primeros cinco millones
de dólares están exentos así que en este
ejemplo donde yo he dado tres millones
de dólares mi hija de hecho va a recibir
los tres millones íntegros ahora
imaginemos que yo tengo mucho más dinero
digamos que tengo seis millones de
dólares en este ejemplo tengo seis
millones de dólares todo esto va a mi
herencia a mi herencia después de mi
muerte y ahora los primeros cinco
millones de dólares están exentos del
impuesto vamos a escribirlo aquí está mi
hija mi hija recibirá los primeros cinco
millones de dólares íntegros
5 millones
pero el incremento por encima de esos 5
millones es decir el millón de dólares
que restan tendrá o se le aplicará el
impuesto
sucesorio la tasa de este impuesto varía
constantemente pero para mantenerlo
simple vamos a inventar que el impuesto
es el 35 por ciento así que el millón de
dólares que resta tendrá un impuesto del
35 por ciento
impuesto del 35 por ciento así que el
gobierno federal de los eeuu le impondrá
el impuesto de 35 por ciento a este
millón de dólares van a quitar 350 mil
para ellos mismos y el resto se lo darán
a mi hija ella recibirá 25 millones 650
mil dólares ya que de este millón al que
le quitaron 350 mil pues le quedarán 650
mil en esta situación mi hija recibiría
recibiría
5.65 millones de dólares
5.65 millones
si yo fuera super rica digamos que yo
tengo vamos a elegir un número con el
que sea más fácil hacer los cálculos
digamos que yo tengo yo tengo mil cinco
millones de dólares
en esta situación imaginaria por
supuesto los primeros 5 millones están
exentos del impuesto
por lo que mi hija
en esa situación
del mil millón de dólares que me queda
le aplicó el 35 por ciento
mil millones al 35%
aquí el gobierno federal se va a quedar
con 350 millones de dólares lo que le
dejará
650 millones de dólares a mi hija
en total tendrá estos 650 millones de
dólares para los 5 millones de dólares
que fueron exentos del impuesto tendrá
un gran total de 655 millones de dólares
y realmente no me preocuparía por el
futuro de ella con esta cantidad que
heredaría y todo esto es para que
ustedes comprendan cómo funciona el
impuesto sucesorio estos ejemplos que
vienen en el que están exentos 5
millones se trata para el impuesto de
herencia individual cuando una persona
fallece pero si esto se hace como una
pareja la cantidad que se exenta es de
10 millones por ejemplo si entre mi
esposo y yo tuviéramos estos mil 5
millones de dólares y digamos que bueno
yo fallezca y tenemos compartido los
bienes él va a recibir toda esta
cantidad completa y cuando a él le
corresponda fallecer serán 10 millones
los que estén exentos en este caso si
fuera de edad o en pareja mi hija
recibiría completo los 6 millones de
dólares algo interesante del impuesto
sucesorio es que las personas debaten
mucho al respecto de si este impuesto es
justo o no es justo les voy a exponer
cuáles son los argumentos a favor en
contra y ya ustedes decidirán si están
de acuerdo o no en ello como la mayoría
de los impuestos siempre habrá alguien
que diga que no es justo vamos a
escribir los argumentos a favor y en
contra
de este impuesto las personas que están
en contra dicen oigan esto no es justo
porque durante toda mi vida trabajé para
ganarme ese dinero pague todos los
impuestos que me dijeron y ahora las
cosas que les quiero dejar a mis seres
queridos a mis herederos no se los podré
entregar todo completo a ellos porque
como vemos estos 600 55 millones no son
suficientes y ellos merecen los mil
millones de dólares que yo trabajé ese
es el argumento de que no es justo algo
como un impuesto doble el dinero que
tuvo un impuesto la primera vez que se
ganó y ahora se le da otro impuesto
cuando se va a heredar el
contraargumento de esto es que el doble
impuesto está en todos lados las
corporaciones pagan impuestos ellos dan
dividendos los inversionistas pagan
impuestos también ustedes pagan
impuestos en sus ingresos y después de
que pagan los impuestos ustedes van a
encontrar cosas en la tienda y también
tienen impuestos los objetos que se
compran así que el doble impuestos
ocurre en todas partes el argumento a
favor el contraargumento de que no es
justo es que dicen mira se estan
exentando los primeros 5 o 10 millones
de dólares 5 a 10 millones de dólares
están exentos del impuesto y viendo esta
cantidad podemos decir que bueno los
herederos no van a sufrir o no se van a
quedar pobres si de entrada reciben esta
cantidad de herencia ellos recibirán en
su casa su auto todo lo que ustedes
tengan siempre y cuando sea menor a los
5 o los 10 millones de dólares
dependiendo del caso que no es una
cantidad pequeña y además de eso se
obtendrá el 65 por ciento de todo lo que
esté por encima de este rango no es como
que sus herederos van a padecer hambre
de hecho es muy poco el número de
personas a los que se les aplica este
impuesto incluso en la clase media muy
pocos de ellos podrán dejar tras de sí
10 millones de dólares el otro argumento
a favor es que si se van a cobrar
impuestos tenemos que ver a qué se le va
a cobrar el impuesto pues se graba o se
saca impuestos de los para que el
gobierno federal tenga algunas entradas
es mejor poner impuestos a alguien que
no trabajo para ganar ese dinero alguien
que solo está obteniendo el dinero y a
lo mejor ya tuvieron todos los otros
privilegios en la vida las mejores
escuelas buenas conexiones a lo mejor
buenos trabajos porque no cobrarle el
impuesto a la persona que ya tiene la
suerte hasta cierto punto de tener todo
esto de todas maneras están recibiendo
lo suficiente para vivir a lo mejor si
reciben menos tendrán más incentivo para
trabajar y el otro argumento a favor de
este impuesto y eso tiene que ver con la
visión general de las cosas de lo que
puede ser lo mejor para la sociedad es
que si no se tiene este tipo de
impuestos nosotros sabemos que existen
grandes fortunas en el mundo en donde
alguien crea un gran imperio de negocios
generan miles de millones de dólares y
si alguien por ejemplo tiene diez mil
millones de dólares
10.000 millones de dólares y digamos que
no tienen tantos herederos o tantos
hijos a lo mejor sólo tienen un hijo y
le dejan estos 10 mil millones a esta
única persona y esta persona puede
literalmente tomar este ingreso ganar un
interés pasivo al respecto y jamás tener
que trabajar por el resto de su vida y
eso es le va a agregar estas ganancias y
este dinero que a lo mejor durante el
curso de la vida de este niño llega a
crecer hasta 30 mil millones de dólares
esto crecerá más rápido de lo que crece
la economía y esta persona si no
existiera este impuesto pues le daría a
estos 30 mil millones de dólares a sus
hijos y eso seguiría creciendo
sucediendo lo mismo generación tras
generación por lo que al final esta
familia si vemos que la persona que creó
este imperio comercial digamos que este
es el producto interno bruto de todo el
país y justo cuando comienza el imperio
comercial de esta persona esa es su
proporción del producto interno bruto
eso es por simplicidad que lo dibujo así
pero si no se cobran impuestos esto
pasivamente durante el transcurso de la
vida del heredero si no es suficiente
hijos sobre los cuales repartir este
imperio conforme va creciendo el
producto interno bruto las inversiones
pasivas crecerán todavía más rápido así
que durante el tiempo esta familia
comenzará a tener una mayor parte del
bienestar de la nación por lo que con el
paso del tiempo estaríamos teniendo aquí
una especie de nobleza y muchas personas
en eeuu ven que esto es la diferencia
entre los estados unidos-inglaterra o
países que tienen nobles es por lo que
solía suceder en términos de la
revolución francesa y la gente que le
daba tierras generación tras generación
y nunca tenían que trabajar y esto que
tenemos aquí es una cita de winston
churchill sobre su opinión acerca del
impuesto de la herencia y lo vea como un
cierto correctivo en contra del
desarrollo de una raza de ricos flojos
así que esa es la explicación de este
impuesto ustedes tendrán su opinión si
están a favor o en contra pero al menos
espero que esto les haya dado las
herramientas para que puedan
comprenderlo